comment ça va j'aime pas qu'on me
suivent
deux choses vont arriver d'abord le
téléphone qui est là va se mettre à
sonner
ensuite vous aurez ses menottes aux
poignets ça ne s'arrêtera pas de sonner
vous êtes qui nom de dieu celui que vous
n'attendiez pas
jack reacher toutes ses décorations vous
êtes une légende raconte quoi d'autre
j'ai besoin de votre aide
quelqu'un tue des soldats des hommes qui
étaient sous votre commandement
là c'est l'heure de la chasse je sais
pas ce qui vous motive
je vous jure que je t'envoie la réponse
personne ne trouvera rien et si j'était
un lâche et le bras pour te massacrer
avec
richer est trop près comment ça va
j'aime pas comment suivre
car nos morts elle nous en tout cas ça
c'est sûr c'est de la peur que j'entends
dans ta foi jack c'est l'excitation que
tu entends dans ma voix
il sent pas très bien je vous conseille
c'est là
comment ça va j'aime pas qu'on vous
suive
il ya deux choses qui vont se passer
dans pardon d'abord le téléphone qui l'a
façonné ensuite ses menottes seront vos
poignets vous êtes qui nom de dieu celui
que vous n'attendiez pas
on se demande pourquoi vous avez
raccroché il ya sept grosses marques de
coups là sur le dessus il paraît que
vous avez fait c'est avec la tête des
cultures j'ai besoin de votre aide
ils ont tué mes hommes
des soldats qui étaient sous vos ordres
je sais ce que tu as fait
tu aurais dû rester en dehors de ça vous
m'avez suivi jusqu'ici c'est pas mal un
sérieux messieurs c'est moi qui me fais
des idées on le salaire de vous réjouir
vous avez une façon assez particulière
de dire merci
il sent pas très bien je vous conseille
celle là qu'est ce qui s'est passé la
bague à un seul mec les ai tous est allé
à l'onu
il est encore dedans tournez vous
monsieur montrez moi vos mains doucement
causé blessure c'est un crime dans notre
état monsieur reacher passer des
menottes et au trot
il ya deux choses qui vont se passer
dans les 90 secondes demande pardon
d'abord le téléphone qui l'a façonné
ensuite ses menottes seront vos poignets
quand vous irez en prison elle est bâtie
dans voilà une prédiction qui me laisse
sans voix monsieur rituel il va pas
s'arrêter de sonner
merci nous avons appris vous venez quand
à washington j'arrête pas de bouger
toutes ses décorations vous êtes une
légende on se demande pourquoi vous avez
raccroché
je me suis levé un matin uniforme mal et
plus jack reacher pour le majeur turner
le majeur torner a été arrêté on
l'accuse de quoi d'espionnage c'est un
coup monté
il en sait beaucoup ce rituel comment ça
va j'aime pas qu'on suive
tu te prends invincibles c'est ça c'est
ça et si j'étais un chef bras pour te
massacrer avec faudra pas mon jeu voire
oui ils sont là pour vous éliminer
mes hommes ont été tués par l'un des
nôtres c'est plus gros que je
l'imaginais ça vous est déjà arrivé de
perdre un de vos gars
tu es un homme mort
vous vous croyez au dessus de la loire
mais je suis pas la loi
vous mettre à courir parce que je vais
me mettre en chasse et quand je vous
trouverai je vous tuerai tous
c'est la coupe de cheveux vous avez tous
le même coiffeur